given that the Oscars have all white
actors nominated uh-huh and Selma which
was an incredibly powerful film was
completely overlooked what do you think
about the state of diversity and
specifically black folks in filmmaking
in the industry we have to understand
that that Hollywood has been a been one
of the most racist institutions in this
country and nobody talks about that
if you look at a movie from the 30s and
40s and 50s you did not see a black
person in the movie unless they were
made I mean they weren't even walking by
on the street and this was conscious you
know they constantly cut out you know
black people I mean I - Ames black we
didn't even work at the studios I mean
they just that people don't exist and
that's the legacy of Hollywood it's like
when you see an old movie I mean this is
how it feels to be a black person you
see no movie you see a black where's our
walk on the scene you know they're made
you're like oh god here it comes
I think that what it's done is it's made
up our relationship as african-americans
very different from white people's
relationship one thing that would help
is if Hollywood would recognize you know
this is where we come from so how do we
get to here so part of what's happened
with selma is that there's not very many
black people in the academy who are
voting on these films you know that's
part of the legacy of racism of
hollywood the academies come under a lot
of fire for its lack of diversity the LA
times track down thousands of members in
2012 and found that 94% of them were
white and 77% were men all with a median
age of 62